bruno merga ban chef du service de
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière
renommée gardanne bonjour et merci
d'être avec nous sur rt france alors la
vaccination débute dimanche deux
établissements précurseur en seine saint
denis et adam la côte d'or
comment ont-ils été elle choisit ses
établissements alors effectivement les
autorités sanitaires ont décidé de
commencer la vaccination par les
personnes âgées qui habitent dans les
ehpad ainsi que le personnel à haut
risque de comorbidité qui y travaillent
alors par la suite je crois que ce sont
des accords avec les responsables de ces
autorités sanitaires régionales et
notamment pour l'assistance publique
hôpitaux de paris
c'est ce service de long séjour qui a
été choisi comment la crainte d'une
troisième vague et elle été appréhendé
dans votre hôpital alors pour le moment
on en est qu'à des hypothèses évidemment
une prédiction d'un risque possible de
troisième vague aujourd'hui à l'hôpital
la situation en ile de france est sous
contrôle
nous avons environ 50 % des lits de
réanimation médicale qui sont occupés
par des patients ayant lakovic 19
ce sont des patients qui sont entrés
déjà depuis un mois un mois et demi ils
présentent tous des formes extrêmement
graves d'infection
ils sont pour la quasi-totalité intubé
et ventilé
leur pronostic vital est engagé
néanmoins depuis maintenant quelques
jours nous avons beaucoup moins de
nouveaux entrants on voit bien que
l'épidémie a légèrement décru même si
comme vous le savez nous sommes arrêtés
sur un plateau malheureusement trop peu
élevé trois à quatre fois plus que ce
que l'on aurait préféré ce qui laisse
présager d'un possible rebond vers la mi
janvier
est-ce que vous pensez que le lancement
de la campagne de vaccination aura un
réel impact sur
them by alors il est trop tôt
malheureusement pour mesurer un
quelconque impact épidémiologique de la
vaccination
en fait il faut savoir que il y à deux
injections à 21 jours d'intervalle
et pour que la réponse immunitaire soit
effective il faut compter une quinzaine
de jours après la deuxième injection
donc en tout il faut attendre un mois et
demi probablement avant que la personne
vaccinée soit réellement immunisés et
qu'elle puisse se défendre contre toute
infection par la coved 19 donc en
pratique évidemment la vaccination va
commencer dès dimanche elle va aller
crescendo mais très probablement les
personnes les plus à risque de décès ne
seront vaccinés que des verts le début
crainte du printemps et donc il faut
attendre encore la fin du printemps pour
pouvoir mesurer un quelconque effet sur
l'épidémie en termes notamment
d'admissions à l'hôpital est en
réanimation
alors on le sait c'est une prouesse
scientifique ce vaccin lancé en
seulement 11 mois c'est un record
mais ce qu'on peut craindre qu'il soit
inefficace vis-à-vis de la mutation du
virus qu'on observe en afrique du sud ou
au royaume uni alors non il est très peu
probable que ces mutations met
compromettent l'efficacité du vaccin
il faut savoir que le corps navires us
subi des mutations qui sont des choses
tout à fait naturel et spontané qui
arrivent pour tous les virus
on estime à une dizaine de milliers de
mutation déjà survenus depuis un an dont
quelques milliers touchant la protéine
spahic c'est à dire la protéine qui sert
au virus pour entrer dans les cellules
alors le vaccin en fait est
essentiellement constituée donc par la
rn messager qui code pour cette protéine
et qui a pour but de déclencher une
réponse immunitaire à la fois par des
anticorps mais aussi par des cellules t
dirigée contre cette protéine
si cette protéine est muté à un niveau
très ponctuel et bien il y à peu à
penser que la réponse immunitaire sera
altérée parce que celle-ci évidemment
possède beaucoup de facettes avec des
anticorps différents qui peuvent contrer
la protéine par des facettes différentes
et donc cette mutation
probablement ne compromettra pas le
vaccin
néanmoins évidemment laisse penser qu'à
terme les mutations se multipliant il
faille probablement se réintéresser à
l'efficacité du vaccin actuel dernière
question
rapidement il ya les contraintes de
production et d'acheminement qui
pourrait être aussi un frein à cette
vaccination massive selon vous alors oui
effectivement il faut bien savoir ce
vaccin à base d'ail rennes message est
un vaccin tout à fait nouveau avec une
technologie très récente
la rn messager et est un composé
extrêmement fragile qui se dégrade très
rapidement il faut donc le conserver à
des températures très basses de l'ordre
de moins 80 degrés donc bien sûr ceci
nécessite que les hôpitaux les centres
de vaccination soit et possèdent ce type
de congélateurs et permette
l'acheminement des vaccins vers les
pharmaciens ou les médecins qui vont
vacciner est extrêmement rapidement et
de façon adaptée aux patients qui vont
se faire vacciner car malheureusement on
ne peut pas garder le vaccin à
température d'un fruit d'un frigo normal
plus de cinq jours
donc effectivement ceci constitue une
certaine limite
je crois que les pays occidentaux où les
capacités évidemment de faire face à
cette contingence par contre bien sûr
très clairement pour la vaccination
deux des autres
pays donc notamment les pays les plus
pauvres eh bien ça sera un défi
probablement inatteignable et donc pour
eux évidemment les vagues simple
classique devront être ceux qui vont
permettre de protéger la population car
évidemment nous sommes devant une
pandémie mondiale et le but est de
protéger la totalité de la population de
la planète
merci beaucoup bonhomme égard ban elle
doit répondre à la question je rappelle
que vous êtes chef du service de
réanimation à l'hôpital lariboisière